now despite inflation surging joe biden
and the new extreme new deal socialist
democrats continue to double down on
their reckless multi-trillion dollar
spending plans
they're trying to turn their far left
socialist fantasies
into your nightmare reality but remember
inflation
that is just really another tax on you
the american people what is inflation it
means you're paying more
for consumer goods you know the cost of
food the cost of building look at the
price of a 2x4 today transportation
costs
all going up the consumer price index
jumped a whopping 4.2 percent
compared to april one year ago now
combine that with a weak jobs report
and the fact that some americans are
being paid more money to actually stay
home than go back to work
which is why a lot of republican
governors have decided
they don't want the extra unemployment
money and by the way you look at all of
this and you have the
the makings of a carter-like disastrous
economy under the leadership of the ever
so weak
frail and well cognitive mess joe biden
here to explain more she's a host of
mornings with maria
maria bartoromo is with us maria it's
great to have you i know it's hard to
book you because you're ours thanks for
staying up tonight
um i'm looking at inflation i'm looking
at
this gash hack shut down
but even prior to that gas prices are
going up and here's my overall question
joe biden's been saying americans if you
make over 400
000 a year you're not going to be paying
taxes
okay isn't all of this a tax on
everybody because every consumer good
when you pay more for fuel and you have
inflation we're going to be paying
dramatically higher prices for
everything we consume
am i wrong no sean you're not wrong it
is great to be with you tonight
you are spot on we are looking at
inflation
on so many products take the price of
lumber it is up
77 year-to-date the price of corn up
50 percent year-to-date we learned in
school that inflation is
too many dollars chasing too few goods
that was the definition we learned about
in school
when you start throwing money around
another four trillion dollars
going toward the economy that is going
to lift prices and that is exactly what
we're seeing
probably the best move for joe biden
would have been to just
stay out of the way leave the economy as
is given the fact that the federal
reserve has kept interest rates at rock
bottom levels
president trump put in a tax cut plan in
2017
and all of this together truly moved the
needle on economic growth
we have expectations for the economy in
2021
of growth of up to nine percent all
president biden needed to do was not
mess
that up get out of the way instead he's
throwing a lot of money at this economy
creating inflation and you're actually
seeing because of this lockdown that
continues to persist
even with the no mask mandate now people
do not want to go to work you just
mentioned all of those states 16 states
at least have said we don't want this
300 additional unemployment benefits
we're getting rid of it now we need to
start normalizing
unfortunately i'm looking at all of
these policies sean and i'm having a
really hard time
finding any policy out of this
administration that's actually been
good for the american people look at the
border look at the amount of illicit
narcotics coming into the
to the border not to mention the 100 000
plus
got aways we don't know who they are we
don't know where they're going we don't
know what they had their intentions are
then you've got the xl pipeline when was
the last time you expected to see
gas lines look at washington dc more
than 60 percent of gas stations
out of gas as as far as last night was
concerned
things will slowly but surely come back
because of a
ransom that was actually paid you've got
the xl pipeline
you've got the border you've got the u.s
now talking about getting back into the
iran deal
no wonder we are seeing rockets fly
toward israel
once again president trump handed the
bad administration
peace in the middle east it's quite
extraordinary what has occurred
in just 114 days so far
and counting sean that's an amazing
summary you know i'm thinking about for
example
just just the price of of energy alone
let's
look at that because it's only it's been
going higher
and what was really i mean people need
to understand everything you buy at
lowe's and home depot
a trucker brought that in for you uh
everything you buy at your grocery store
or drugstore
or liquor store if you want to drink i
don't know it's friday tonight you might
want to have a drink
we're going to be paying more for
everything here now
because trucking companies aren't going
to they're not going to
make less per mile truckers they're
going to feel the impact of inflation as
well they're going to want more money
not less money to make up for
the the price of of paying for their own
goods
so now this impacts every single
american
now you add that to americans don't want
to go back to work
uh because they're making more money and
and i don't see a light at the end of
the tunnel where joe is saying
okay it's time to get back to work and
we're going to fully open up
if you don't open up then these people i
guess will get this money in perpetuity
and
every business will continue to struggle
well you're right i mean one of the
reasons we're not seeing light at the
end of the tunnel
is because there's no acknowledgment of
the impact of these policies yes you're
right we're seeing
prices for commodity goods the things
that we put on our kitchen table
go higher across the board and yes that
acts as another tax
but guess what that doesn't end there
we're seeing higher taxes on the horizon
when you look at a corporate tax rate of
going from 21
to 28 companies money is mobile
companies will just
move they will acquire other companies
and and put their corporate headquarters
in other company countries like they did
under the obama administration
under the obama administration ireland
had a nine percent corporate tax rate
while
obama had a 35 percent corporate tax
rate what happened
a number of mergers companies acquiring
irish companies moving their
headquarters to ireland
capital gains taxes 20 percent complete
going to
43.4 percent it's not too hard to figure
out what's going to happen with a 43 and
a half percent capital gains tax
the stock market is going to sell off
you're also talking about as you
mentioned 400 000
being the bottom we're still trying to
get clarity out of the bud
administration is that 400 000
per individual is that 400 000 per
family
i understand it's actually per family
that takes you down to
200 000 the people who are gonna get
taxed
not only that it's really not right you
know last thing
uh maria corporations don't pay taxes
they're not going to make less oh
joe wants more of our money no they will
pass that tax on to the consumers as
well
uh great to see you always love you on
hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else